many people along the North Carolina
coast here are heeding the warnings and
getting out of Florence's way in the
Outer Banks most tourists and residents
have packed up and left but mark
Strassmann is in Kitty Hawk at the home
of one man who decided to stay mark good
morning to you good morning ah Jeff
there's the mandatory evacuation order
in effect here all these homes should be
empty but there are always hurricane
hold us one of them is a 71 year old
dick Thompson lifelong resident why risk
it there's always the same amount of
deliberation on every one of these
things it all boils down to home family
friends dear but was so much to lose why
risk it
you're gonna run the same risk anywhere
part of mine you know and I'd rather be
here and knowing what I'm dealing with
then somewhere else and not knowing what
I'm going to be confronted with might
you make a last-minute decision call an
audible and head inland if it looks ugly
I hardly know are you stopped up I'm
here yeah you're here and you're in
you're set to go
nothing's going to change your mind okay
all right well thanks for talking and
stay safe
so this island is also starting to shut
down along with the bridge that leads to
Virginia one of two main bridges that
lead to the Outer Banks it will become a
one-way bridge and only people can get
off they can't get on the ferry to
Ocracoke Island is now suspended service
this island is essentially gearing up
hoping for the best but trying to make
sure that they're safe in case the storm
makes a sudden last-minute turn and
heads this way Jeff all right mark
thanks a lot the the major message for
folks here in the impact zone is don't
get complacent keep watching the
forecast even though the storm is
weakening still incredibly dangerous for
those who have stayed on the coast there
is still time to get out if people need
to again the big concern that flooding
we're gonna in 36 hours now from John so
if you if you think about that 12 or 13
foot storm surge we're all gonna be
under water here if we're in this
location we're not planning to be right
here but that's what we're expecting in
Wilmington and for hundreds of miles
potentially in parts up and down the
North Carolina coast John back to you in
the studio in New York all right Jeff
thank you